we're rolling and you're rolling in this
movie it is absolutely amazing it is
Rolly emotional and I'm a mother of two
girls so I'm still thinking about the
movie and everything that you had to go
this is one of your best performances
ever really it truly is and I've known
you for how many years it really is and
in those moments in the movie you really
did have to tap into the loss of a loved
one this must have been a very emotional
I'm joking I'm just thinking about it
for you to do this character is this
movie was such a crazy whirlwind of
emotions for me because I filmed the
movie till about up until four days
before I got married but it was one of
the joyous moments of my life where you
know I'm you know like in union with the
man of my dreams and at the same time
channeling the sense of loss that I felt
tremendously equivalent when my dad died
but not myself like I used her as a
conduit so much like the ice to talk to
shonali
I'm a very directors actor but I also
imbibed from from my surroundings and
the kind of actor that means to I feel
I'm sensitive
I need a feed off of people and shonali
is experience of the loss of her son
when he was 16 and how she dealt with
life her relationship her point of view
on death and on loss and how she - just
like me and my mom turned turned this
incident into a celebration of the
person's life instead of you know the
the mourning of the void so instead of
like just thinking about the sad the
fact that they're gone it's gonna happen
to all of us we're all going the only
thing that we know but we are the only
thing we really know is birth and death
right I don't mean to be philosophical
but and the movie kick-starts like that
it's lovely cuz it's like it's the kids
voice and she says she says it in the
movie that you know we're all gonna die
one day right so let's just get that out
of the way
and now let me tell you about the movie
so I I love her tone and her take on on
death which is something common for all
of us and how she flipped it on her head
but telling this extremely true story
every scene in this movies actually
happened yeah really
everything everything everything is has
been narrated to her but and us by
real-life oddity any rain every seemed
hey Charlie for you to see this story
unfold and seeing Priyanka take on this
role as a mother and from your own
experiences this must be a very proud
moment for you hugely proud I mean I
think she was my first choice always so
she I just wanted her even when I was
writing and I visualized who should play
at the teach Audrey it was Priyanka so
it was a dream but I couldn't access her
so I sort of was like give it because
she's busy
I like whoever like I who you know I I
could not get the script into her hands
like they said that they will get it or
they will get a turn and so then when
Sid came on board as a producer and I
said this is the person I want can you
get me this actor and then he did so
that itself was a dream come true and
that happened on my son ASEAN's birthday
like it was his birthday I was in LA and
I woke up to a text saying she's read
the script and can you fly to New York
so right then I knew this film was
blessed and so connected with him and
then in meeting her in New York and her
Fartman right away we bonded on that
exactly as she said about Asian and my
relationship with Jean and I left just
euphoric like I went down from apartment
I just jumped up and down in excitement
because before then I was itching to
direct her like I just I felt like she
hadn't plumbed the depths of her talent
yet like she was very very good but like
I really felt like she can go much
deeper and she and she hadn't got those
characters yet perhaps to just because
she has that ability to do that to put
herself in the skin of the character and
has the ability to go very deep
emotionally and I hadn't seen that yet
on-screen and I it's been exciting to
director and to get that and what a
performance you know that out of her I
just I a very first scene in which like
it just got yes I got goose bumps I did
yeah when I was directing I'm saying
and I told and I hugged her and she
answered by saying like it brought me to
tears because she said babe
I just connected with you and I Shawn
that's the first time she said that to
me I didn't know that that's what she
was doing and that that was just the
best thing for me and this is a
celebration of life and it's a love
story that we're celebrating 25 years
we're seeing this couple go through all
these struggles and these hurdles losing
a child losing two kids now you're
married
what are something that you would say
that keeps a relationship healthy and
how this movie shows the healthiness of
a relationship um just like in this
movie I think it's communication
something I didn't know much about
listen I shut down when when I have
issues I'm not it's hard for me to talk
it takes a lot I'll do it like I'll come
up to you I don't like conflict so I
don't like sitting in conflict I'd
rather have a conversation knock it out
and just go back to doing what you have
to do but I think communication in the
relationship is key and that was that's
something you lose when something like
that happens to you and I've seen that
with a few people that I know who have
lost their children and I really
channeled into that and you see that in
this movies and that really happened to
additi any rain that they separate and
then they come back and they separate
it's like it comes and goes in waves
some relationships survive that some
relationships tone theirs did and I
think that communication is key and it's
something that I've learned since I've
been married and actually Nick taught me
that I'm I I'm not someone who's good at
it I get awkward my toes curl but you
know what's so great to see you as a
mother and you in the future when you do
have kids will you beat that mom who
will take out the camera take some shots
I'm every little thing that happens with
your child I hope so yeah you will be
that parent know what kind of fair
enough I just think the enormity of the
gratitude of just having yeah a child I
think would be so amazing both of you
are moms and
it's now that I'm married it's really
something that you know is on your brain
like I I can't wait I think it'll be
amazing whenever God she's really good
with baby see we had a lot of it and cry
sometimes when you don't need them to
and that's hard like that's hard even if
your mother and used to a baby and she's
terrific with babies and she she had to
do that so much but she's also terrific
with young people so she needed to form
that relationship with the actors IRA
and Rohit to make them comfortable as I
shine each on because she's a global
star you know and she had to make them
comfortable as actors so she's got an
ability with teenagers as well as with
babies which was so important for her as
an actor to get those performances from
whether from a baby or from a teenager
and I think that's what's also terrific
and I love the fact that you're making
this movie happen here at TIFF and you
you've been to tip so many times and
you're working on a lot of project that
are creating a representation diversity
and women of color and you're working
with Mindy Kaling on a wedding movie as
well is that a reflection of your own
wedding experiences actually did come up
from that did it really and it's a
comedy it's the comedy of my wedding did
you have you kind of step back and kind
of absorbed everything all the pictures
you haven't like I don't have an album
and we still haven't seen all the
pictures yeah I've never even seen the
video like your mom hasn't meet you sit
down and watch it that's the anything to
do we just haven't had that it's just so
much that we have been doing both of us
in terms of work and travel and we have
a lifetime to do that that's fine
but like this movie the one with Mindy
literally came up with me and my team
were sitting and talking about like what
do we want to do and and one of them
suggested that um you know I'm you like
thought about collaborating Mindy
because I was collaborating with a bunch
of my friends I was like why didn't I
think of that it's such a no-brainer
yeah so I called her and I said you want
to do something together let's just meet
let's just go for lunch and see what
comes out of it we went for lunch
started talking about my wedding and our
precarious relationships with the US and
India and I start telling her about the
funny things that started happening at
the
and we were like that's what the movie
should be that's how I developed it was
just really funny
weddings are funny be yard like how long
was yours like 50 days four days four
days that's like four days and then when
we had to have a few reception of course
this is my mom so my mom made a deal
with me yeah that I was allowed only 180
like I would be able to do a small
wedding which is 180 people if she had
the ability to have receptions wherever
she could call the jeweler is the the
sorry guy the chef's that everyone had
to be called so I just didn't want the
wedding to be so we made a deal that's
what we had that many exceptions like
maybe you finally know and now we know
and finally your YouTube page you say
that you asked the question if I can
tell you just one thing what would that
be if I could tell you just one thing Oh
sit back when you do it why you gotta be
like I don't know I'd get right into the
conversation no it's really cute I love
that it's just backstage I think telling
you to sit back but if I could tell you
one thing I think it would be you know
to try and a lot of us don't do this but
it's this new thing I'm attempting is
try and find the balance between work
and life I've spent so much time not
living life my mom always says that I
have so many stamps in my passport but
I've never really seen anything which is
true so last year I decided that I'm
gonna experience things too like when I
come for TIFF I'm gonna go out for
dinner you know do things and like so
that would be my one thing to you is
don't forget to experience life because
it's really short love you thank you so
much